in 1519 during the spanish conquest of
mexico hernan cortes ordered his men to
burn their ships
he did this to give his men a choice
facing an empire he forced a point of no
return for himself
and his men
conquer or die
for cortes there was no going back
you've heard it a million times
in a million different ways
a line in the sand
crossing the event horizon
point of no return
crossing the rubicon
burn the ships
burn
the
ships
for a modern entrepreneur
there is no going back
we see our goal and we will achieve it
or we will die trying sounds great
sounds sexy
but who really believes that
who is truly willing to go all in
to block out the negativity
the haters the doubters the all-nighters
no weekends
to make your dream a reality
and fulfill your destiny
to destroy the idea of a backup plan
and burn
your ships
[Music]
[Applause]
we are all at the footsteps of empires
but all empires can fall
now more than ever
with the constant distractions and
detractors
we must be steadfast in our vision
and when there's nowhere behind us to go
our only path is forward
towards success
towards our dreams
towards our destiny
[Music]
we are ready
are you